teams need stars stars are really
valuable the top 6% of physicists
published fifty percent are the
responsible fifty percent of all the
research papers and physics that are
published a star all-star immunologist
that bring up their colleagues quality
of work by thirty-five percent you need
stars but stars see teams as black holes
people who are going to free ride people
are going to take credit for their work
people aren't going to work is hard and
if you want to get stars onto a team you
have to not assume that just telling
them forced collaboration is going to be
the rule of the day and instead you have
to convince them that what they can
accomplish will be far greater on the
team that anything they could accomplish
alone